Lando is on the line in Florida hi
Roland oh how are you better than I
deserve what's up so I will tell you all
everything pretty much um okay I have a
house too much of a mortgage I paid
$2,000 in my mortgage I have a car
$13,000 loan credit cards fifteen
hundred sixteen hundred and four
thousand I'm out of a job cause what the
court of iris what were you doing I'm
all poke at you during a casino
okay and how much were you making I'll
figure it out polish okay all right and
how long have you been out to open a
half-volley you just watch six series
okay yeah
or have you been collecting unemployment
I tried or for some odd reason I don't
know why I thought he did something
wrong but um I got unintelligible so I
reapplied again okay
is your wife work outside the home oh
yeah she works um a behavior therapist
she makes around 2,500 per month okay
out and are you have you been doing any
have you been doing any work
shouldn't you got laid off I tried to
apply so few places but nobody's really
hard I really tried I literally apply
for people everywhere totally I was
talking a few plays must call me but
then they said all qualified like okay
thank you I work for my friend for a
little bit so he's like really really
bad and I am I'm trying to look for
another job that pays a little bit
better at least toxic bring her OSI wife
it's like she doesn't reason she's
taking maternity leave and it's two
months Wow
yeah I'm pretty good at all the good
thing is I have an air beefy in my house
a tiny house in the back and not bring
the level of them people running it yes
right now yeah right now I got really
lucky I got running it out for three
whole months so I'm lucky enough for
that okay very good
oh that's good news
okay so you have a you really what you
have is a career crisis more than
anything right yeah you gotta find some
work yeah you got all outgoing a win
come III go to school at home and how I
should go today I have to pay three
dollars cash no you're broken don't have
a job no I won't have $50 my CD account
okay but you don't I mean you got you
got a card debt that's equal to that
just about and you got a $2,000 a month
house payment and you got no job
how you gonna survive if you go to
school I don't know that's what I what
to do an idea I wanted to go to school
and I finally could go on all of this
happen and it's just I bet if they dr.
Sam and I'm stressed out I would love
for you to go to school if you want to
study something what are you gonna study
school so that's why I did I'm doing a
five week course for EMP and I'm always
hoping to get our jobs right away after
that then after that August 30th all
right cool okay well the five week job
makes sense and if you're an EMT you can
go to firefighter school while you're an
EMT right while you're on the payroll
yeah yeah you need to get payroll coming
in and so if you isn't is that what you
want to do with your life okay well I
mean that's okay I thought you were
going to a four-year college or
something but if you're gonna go for a
few notes you're gonna spend $3,000 of
your eighteen and go for a few weeks and
that gets you a job in the area that you
want to be in anyway then that makes a
ton of sense yeah
now when does a EMT school start okay so
you need to be working your butt off
delivering pizzas are working for Amazon
delivering stuff or shelving putting
groceries on the shelves at Publix or
whatever those people are all hiring
every one of them are hiring right now
they're all overwhelmed and they need
help
construction site I don't care go work
for a month about 80 hours a week you
got a baby on the way and you don't want
to be burning up this 18,000 bucks it's
precious money right now you won't be
burning it up with living it with $2,000
house payments because there's no income
to mount anything coming in the house
and you can't live on your wife's 2500
not with a $2,000 house payment and a
car payment that money's going poof just
like that so you got to do something to
get your income up until you get into
EMT school and then head into that and
then you can survive through that one
month and get your training or that six
weeks and get your training and then
come out you better have a job lined up
on the other side of that and if you do
then this is going to be a good plan by
this time next year and you're gonna be
in a good place
hey thanks for the call brother